[Music]
the way animals are constructed and
built it's awe-inspiring and partly
because I'm a very visual person so
morphology I find it to be beautiful in
a way that art is beautiful
[Music]
I had since I was very young just a
particular interest in reptiles really
just an aesthetic thing I can't explain
it I just always like them
when a lot of lizards feed they're using
their tongues to capture prey not their
jaws not their teeth and they're using
their tongues to manipulate the food
when it's in the mouth and I just began
to realize if I wanted to understand
feeding function I needed to understand
something about the tongues
when I was just a beginning graduate
student I was talking to another young
member of the department and he said oh
do you know what you're going to study
and I said yeah I'm going to work on
lizard tongues and he burst out laughing
so I realized at this early stage that
I'm going to have to explain to people
why this is
interesting
I see lizard and snake tongues as being
my Darwin's finches they're this
incredibly variable system and we can
start understanding the diversity in
terms of how one lineage optimized the
sensory function of the tongue and this
other lineage they've optimized the
feeding function of the tongue you look
at other lineages and you find really
interesting compromises where they try
to do both functions and that's exactly
what we're trying to understand we're
trying to understand the basis of
diversity
when you are interested in the
functional aspect
it typically happens so fast you can't
see it finally we got to the place where
video now the the video resolution and
frame rate is astonishing
so it just opened a whole new world on
this Behavior I was interested in and so
anything that comes across into my view
I try to put in front of a high-speed
camera
foreign
you see things that you had no idea were
happening things that were unpredictable
I've been studying specifically how
chameleons are able to hold on to their
prey so effectively people have thought
it was pretty much just stickiness
but what I've learned is that they
actually with their tongues they're able
to wrap around and grasp the prey item
it looks like a pair of lips or maybe
the tips of an elephant trunk it's an
astonishing
there are salamanders that don't
actually project the tongue but just
have this very soft compliant blob in
the mouth and it's it's very dramatic it
just kind of goes blah it's so soft and
gooey looking it's bizarre it contacts
the prey item and right at the point of
contact and the tongue surface begins to
fold into a vertical crease and so it
gets pinched between two surfaces it's
never been described before
foreign
we just had some tadpoles in the lab
because we were actually studying
feeding in larval salamanders and the
larval salamanders would eat tadpoles so
they were swimming around in a tanks and
I was just sitting there staring at them
and I saw the tadpole swim really fast
up to the surface of the water it to
swim up and swim away and then a little
bubble came out of its mouth I couldn't
figure out what it had done so well it
turned out it was breathing air
and that wasn't social I mean it's
actually unknown to many people that
tadpoles have lungs and breathe air most
of them do but what turned out to be
particularly interesting was the way
they were breathing air I assumed it was
a well-known Behavior but I you know you
have to keep in mind that things like
high resolution high-speed video I
haven't been around that long so people
have been studying tadpoles for a long
time but they didn't have the benefit of
these tools and so it turns out this was
a novel behavior that no one had ever
seen before and that actually that
single completely chance observation led
to a whole branch of research and a
series of Publications it's the kind of
thing that you can discover by
visualizing something slowing it down
seeing it close up and when you're lucky
you just discover something completely
new
[Music]
research is a very creative process it's
challenging it certainly is not always
rewarding but when you see something so
unexpected or you understand something
that eluded you they are real moments of
you know real highs and every day it's a
possibility that you're going to
discover that next thing
[Music]
foreign